[Musique]
priorité au saucisses oui ça va te faire
plaisir car je sais que tu aimes cette
chanson Patrick aujourd'hui sur BFM
c'était la merguez partie j'ai mangé de
la saucisse grillée des saucisses
ensemble les leaders des 8 principaux
syndicats ont ainsi choisi la préfecture
du Tarn pour manifester et montrer que
la colère s'exprime partout Albi c'est
une ville symbolique de tout ce qui se
passe dans les villes de France qu'on
dit moyenne ou petite mais y compris des
encore plus petites où il y a des
forteaux de mobilisation il y a une
mobilisation incroyable ce qui montre la
profondeur du mouvement Yannick pour les
travailleurs
Nadia Eric retraite bravo il faut dire
que faire grève pour fouler le pavé cela
coûte cher cet employé de Pôle Emploi
fait pour nous les comptes depuis le
début de sa mobilisation
de à peu près 400
euros perdus ouais tout à fait
ça fait beaucoup ça fait beaucoup
qu'est-ce que vous savez combien de
saucisses vous allez vendre aujourd'hui
876 en fait je posais la question sur
les saucisses parce que c'est aussi une
bonne façon de voir la présence vous me
demandiez s'il y avait du monde et oui
c'est vrai que c'est un bon indicateur
découvrons tout de suite les chiffres de
la mobilisation à Paris 150 000
saucisses selon les organisateurs et
Herta 100 000 merguez selon la police et
Madrange et 10 saucisses selon le
cabinet occurrence food et puis nous
avons partagé le quotidien des
Ukrainiens
[Musique]
non ça fait un an qu'on est en guerre
je vous montre cette image qui peut vous
faire peur surtout un genre de redire
regardez ce qui s'est passé au Japon
quand un sanglier surgit sur la piste et
vient attaquer à directement au frontal
un snowboarder mais qu'est-ce qu'il se
passe regardez avec sa planche de
snowboard le sanglier si un bon il ne
relâche pas et là il part se met la
panique dans toute la station
heureusement tout va bien mais ça
pourrait vous arriver tout est possible
il y a une différence entre ce qui est
possible et ce qui est probable voilà
je l'ai perdu
son compagnon Alexandre ne perd pas de
temps et fonce tête baisser vers la
bouée dans une tenue de bain pour le
moins original
j'ai vécu trop de choses on a cours
moment j'ai vu Stéphane le jeu et du
coup je me suis laissé perturber par mes
émotions ils vont tous dans les abris là
oui cela vont par ici et pour les plus
jeunes il y a un deuxième abri
là ici on est à l'école
primaire en pleine alerte vous le voyez
alors là on voit tous les enfants qui
descendent des classes j'ai l'impression
que la directrice en fait elle dit à ses
institutrices de remonter partout dans
les classes pour vérifier s'il y a pas
d'enfants qui sont restés dans les
classes on peut descendre maintenant on
y va aussi alors on y va aussi vas-y
[Musique]
le chapeau parce que pendant le vertige
c'est vrai que c'est pas évident de
faire ce genre de choses je suis très
fière d'elle et très rassurée voilà et
je me lance à la
ah ouais mais c'est dingue
là ce sont les terminales ah ok l'alerte
elle risque de durer vous avez vu il y a
une salle de classe qui est installée en
fait dans l'abri en sous-sol et ils vont
continuer le cours en fait
les alertes c'est souvent 2 3 4 fois par
semaine celle-là c'est la 7e de la
semaine c'est sûr que tu veux pas juste
les filles elles l'ont fait moi
j'ai surpassé des choses que normalement
j'aurais pas fait depuis qu'on est là
excuse
dans l'eau pour l'instant on n'a rien
fait je peux me dire on a fait quelque
chose là
des nouvelles de Jennifer Lopez et Ben
Affleck à 50 ans passés ils se sont fait
faire un tatouage de couple pour la
Saint-Valentin comme des ados la
chanteuse a opté pour un signe infini
une flèche et leur prénom une idée très
datée pour des internautes renvoyait des
années en arrière en 2011 2010 voire
plus loin 2001 les mêmes remarques que
s'appliquent au tattoo de Ben Affleck
avec toutefois un espoir que cette fois
le couple ne se sépare pas j'ai envie
d'y aller à ce moment là vraiment mais
j'arrive pas
je ne peux pas le faire je n'y arrive
pas à le faire
d'oreille
moi
je l'aurais fait pour toi moi je
personnellement au jour d'aujourd'hui
je suis là pour donner le meilleur de
moi-même parce qu'il n'en peuvent plus
des tweets d'Elon musk de nombreux
internautes blocs sont comptes il faut
dire que le milliardaire est omniprésent
depuis quelques jours sur le réseau
social c'est voulu le patron de Twitter
a fait modifier l'algorithme de la
plateforme pour que ses propres tweets
soient plus visibles même chez ceux qui
ne le suivent pas un abus de pouvoir
dont Elon Musk s'amuse avec ce
photomontage de très mauvais goût
ah c'est pour ça qu'ils ont la grosse
souris pour que tout
il parle il postillon moi j'étais là sur
le côté comme ça je me mets en bien en
arrière pour éviter de recevoir ses
éventuels postillons
cette page assemblée avec un détour par
là buvette qui est visiblement à ses
habitudes la valeur du travail c'est
quoi pour le salarié
les filles et le chaleur c'est quoi bah
c'est la cotise le fameux coup de pouce
épaissirez un peu la masse salariale
avez-vous shifté un peu ça
[Musique]
elle arrête de rire on s'aperçoit que il
n'a pas l'air très net donc on a pas le
choix on descend
Nathalie engie viennent de prendre une
sage décision je suis pas venu pour
enfiler des perles ni autre chose
d'ailleurs